we have been talking about it quite a
bit today it's a two-day extension
making ccsd now a five-day pause and
it's going to start on friday that's
right denise a lot of you parents you're
rushing to find accommodations the
school district says this pause is a
bump in the road they say it needs to
happen christian casaros joins us live
in studio with more christian this is
the first time we are hearing from ccsd
speaking out on this that's right brian
and denise well ccsd says its data
indicated a change was necessary after
2300 covid cases surfaced since the new
year
what we need our families to do and all
of our community members to support this
is to stay home stop the spread and
pause ccsd speaking out for the very
first time about the five-day pause
after the spike raised a red flag the
pause is really just for us to catch up
we had an abundance of staff out the
last week and a half
it will give us a chance to ensure that
we give our staff enough time to get
healthy the five-day stretch begins
friday and will roll into the mlk
holiday which was already scheduled off
our message is the same first of all we
understand the inconvenience and we
apologize but we have to think of all of
our students and our staff's safety as
the primary decision for making this
adjustment
these are not instructional days lost
because they were planned in the
calendar for the future it's just being
adjusted parents are being reminded that
school will return to normal in-person
education on wednesday a similar effort
governor steve cyslak is pushing to
avoid falling back to remote learning
we're very confident we have these
mitigating strategies in place and to be
honest i think if we didn't have that
long holiday break with two weeks that
people were together with one another
and traveling we wouldn't be in this
position
well ccsd is reminding both staff and
students to use this time wisely they're
asking folks to get tested and
vaccinated now if cases spike again they
didn't rule out this pause from
happening again christian gaza is live
local now